Checkmate 5 It's a patience, the
light is defeated by the darkness
. It's not over.
Yeah,
don't wait. It's good.
If you become an enemy, you won't lose.
Me
amaran
uh
me
[Music]
Ah ah ah
ni
[Music]
I want to help a lot of people.
I don't feel like losing to
Riku, I think he's got the strength to protect his loved ones
. 4 amaran Is it okay now?
Let's tie
it up I want to get out when I get lost I want to get Elsa back
Hmm, if it's a hole, I can make up 1
I wonder if we have 13 people
already. Let's help us find 6 books.
Another Twilight Town air
ni
Ah ah ah
[Music]
n ame
me
[Applause]
If it doesn't work as expected  It's okay to
erase it Yes, I have to find a strange vessel. It's
true.
Booby I think I was always competing with each other.
I wonder if it's ticking
for a while, but this time is a song, but
we also have a
good blade that unlocks the war
me
[music]